these days it can seem like Hollywood's
got so many sequels on the slate it's
practically impossible to keep track of
them all
never fear though here are a few of the
upcoming sequels prequels and spin-offs
that might have slipped under your radar
many fans thought the day would never
come but it looks like Ridley Scott is
finally making a sequel to the story of
Maximus Decimus Meridius nearly 20 years
after the original gladiator hit
theaters of course all Maximus is busy
walking through wheat fields in heaven
so what's the sequel actually going to
be about according to producer Walter F
Parkes the film is going to begin about
20 to 30 years after the original ended
and according to The Hollywood Reporter
part two will focus on Lucius the son of
Maximus is old flame lucilla while
Spencer treat Clark played lucius in the
first film we don't know if he's going
to reprise his role for gladiator - what
we do know is that Peter Craig is
writing the screenplay and he's a guy
with some pretty impressive credits to
his name including the town both
Mockingjay movies and the upcoming Top
Gun sequel and with Scott himself behind
the camera you can be sure it'll be
nothing if not entertaining based on the
comic book series by Mark Millar and
Dave Gibbons the Kingsmen films have
followed the adventures of gary eggsy
unwin a london street thug who joins an
organization of gentleman spies Nonna's
make
[Music]
man soon enough he finds himself in a
hyper violent world of electric lassos
and bulletproof umbrellas and now
director Matthew Vaughn wants to expand
on the franchise's quirky and messed-up
mythology by finding out how Kingsman
came about in the first place
the King's Man will explain the origins
of the well-dressed intelligence agency
going all the way back to the early 20th
century according to Collider the story
will focus on an egg Z style hero named
Conrad played by Harris Dickinson who
gets involved in World War one while the
exact plot details aren't entirely
certain the film boasts an impressive
lineup of actors including ray Fiennes
Gemma Arterton Charles dance Rhys Evans
tom hollander and Djimon Honsou Collider
also reports that this movie will feel
more like a period drama than a spy
thriller which might make for an
interesting departure from the previous
two Kingsman films whatever Matthew
Vaughn has in store will become clear on
Valentine's Day 2020 ever wonder what
happened to Django and broom-hilda after
they blew candy land to Kingdom Come and
Django Unchained well wonder no more
because it looks like the fastest gun in
the south is riding back into theaters
according to collider Quentin Tarantino
is working on a sequel to Django
Unchained and this time he's teaming up
with one of the most legendary heroes in
vigilante history based on a comic
series co-written by Tarantino and Matt
Wagner the sequel will find Django
forced to escape westwards after burning
down Calvin Candy's plantation and
that's when he runs into a Spanish
nobleman named Diego de la Vega who you
might know better as Zorro that's right
Django is reportedly going to team up
with the famous masked swordsman and
together these two are going to use
bullets and blaze to free the local
indigenous people from some very nasty
bad guys that might sound like an
incredible premise for a sequel but it's
not entirely certain just how involved
Tarantino is going to be with the whole
thing he's ultimately in charge of the
project but the folks at Collider
believe he'll be producing instead of
directing
as for the screenplay comedian Jerrod
Carmichael will be writing the script
but it's also uncertain whether
Tarantino is co-writing with Carmichael
or simply overseeing the screenplays
development one of the most influential
shows and TV history The Sopranos came
to an end in 2007 not with a bang but
with a fade to black the gangster series
earned massive acclaim throughout its
run set the stage for shows like Mad Men
and Breaking Bad and gave us one of
televisions most iconic characters Tony
Soprano now over a decade later the
show's creator David Chase is bringing
his mafia saga to the big screen with
the many saints of Newark a movie that
serves as a prequel to the emmy-winning
series according to Deadline the film
will be set in the 1960s during the
deadly Newark riots and will focus on
Dickie Moltisanti Tony Soprano's mentor
and christopher moltisanti's father the
film will also star the likes of Vera
Farmiga Jon Bernthal Billy Magnussen
Corey Stoll and Leslie Odom jr. and oh
yeah
gangster legend Ray Liotta is also set
to show up the screenplay will be
co-written by chase and acclaimed TV
director Alan Taylor will be sitting in
the director's chair in addition to
working on Thor the dark world and Game
of Thrones taylor also directed several
episodes of The Sopranos which should
make him a natural fit for the prequel
speaking with deadlines Chase explained
this new film will take place in an era
when the mob was a bit more dapper than
they are today
he said it is going to depict when it
was good the Mafia was very polished at
that time how they dressed in what they
did these weren't guys who wore
tracksuits back then but that's not all
a young Tony Soprano is also going to
appear played by none other than Michael
Gandolfini son of James the many saints
of Newark is set for release on
September 25th 2020 while he'd already
won plenty of attention with movies like
boy and eagle vs. shark director Tycho
ytt really broke into the cinematic
consciousness with his supernatural
mockumentary what we do in
shadows starring ytt himself and fellow
New Zealander Jemaine Clement this
improv heavy comedy tells the story of
three vampire roommates just trying to
get by in the 21st century the film
wound up on multiple best of the Year
lists and since then ytt has gone on to
direct a certain little indie picture
you might just have heard of Thor
Ragnarok but despite his new role in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe whitey T is
still eyeing a return to the world of
the undead in January 2016 ytt told
crave online that his shadow sequel will
focus on the werewolf pack led by actor
Rhys Darby nice win sorry werewolves in
June the director explained the plot of
werewolves would focus on a power
struggle between Darby's alpha male and
stew Rutherford's recently transformed
computer programmer
however whitey T has explained that
making werewolves is going to take a
while speaking with IGN the director
said the Jemaine and tyka works is a
very long and slow machine we put an
idea in one end and it takes about six
years to come out the other end and
sometimes it doesn't even come out in
other words rear wolves is still
currently creeping its way through the
creative sausage maker but if you need
your shadows fixed sooner than later you
do well to check out the spin-off shows
set in the same universe
Wellington paranormal and FX is what we
do in the shadow series diehard could
well be the greatest action movie of the
80s in fact it's probably one of the
best action flicks ever made . but let's
be honest the series has suffered in
recent years with the last film bombing
with critics and tanking at the domestic
box office so fingers crossed that
diehard 6 AKA MacLean and bring a bit of
fun back to the franchise according to
Len Wiseman who directed live free or
die hard the new film will jump back and
forth in time similar to The Godfather
Part two in one timeline we'll have
Bruce Willis squaring off against a team
of dastardly terrorists in another
there'll be a younger John McClane
patrolling the streets of 1970s New York
as for the cast there's
word yet on who will play the younger
McLain but Wiseman has promised the
appearance of a young Holly Gennaro who
fans now grows up to become McClain's
wife however there's been a snag in
getting the film to the big screen
diehard was originally owned by 20th
Century Fox but now that Fox has been
bought out by Disney the folks at the
house of mouse have to give the movie
the go-ahead
luckily according to McLain producer
Lorenzo di Bona Ventura Disney does
indeed like the script so at the moment
it looks like diehard 6 is still in play
Master and Commander the far side of the
world is one of those movies everybody
loves today but nobody saw when it was
in theaters starring Russell Crowe as a
british sea captain and paul bettany as
a scientific best bud the film follows
The Adventures of the HMS surprise
during the Napoleonic Wars despite rave
reviews the movies poor box office
performance seemingly sank the chance of
a sequel however in November 2017
Russell Crowe took to Twitter and posted
this cryptic tweet for the Aubrey
Maturin lovers I do hear whispers indeed
that a second voyage is perhaps
potentially pre proposed a possibility
admittedly it's not a lot to go on but
if Crowe is on board for such a massive
undertaking maybe we'll get to see the
further adventures of Captain Jack
Aubrey and dr. Stephen Matt you're in
before long of course as Bettany pointed
out in May 2018 Crowe has a history of
teasing the sequel in hopes of
interesting the people with the pocket
books and there's still no telling
whether there's enough studio interest
to get this project going but if it does
as Bettany put it I would revisit those
waters in a heartbeat based on the novel
by Andrea seaman call me by your name
picked up several Oscar nods at the 90th
Academy Awards and even won the prize
for Best Adapted Screenplay making James
ivory the oldest Oscar winner of all
time the movie made its way onto
multiple best of the Year lists and
inspired by its success director luca
guadagnino has decided he might return
to helm a follow-up at the BFI London
Film Festival the Italian filmmaker said
that he wanted to do a sequel that takes
place several years in the future it
would be set during an era where Timothy
shallow
character Elio would be dealing with the
impact of the Gulf War the fall of the
Soviet Union and the rise of the AIDS
epidemic he also told The Hollywood
Reporter that he wanted Evo to be a
cinephile and the sequel might open with
our protagonist sitting in a theater
watching once more the first French film
to grapple with the subject of AIDS
gwah Nino is also considering an entire
series of films that follow Elio and his
lover Oliver as they grow older right
now this is all very theoretical but
Guadagnino is reportedly serious about
pursuing a sequel an army hammer has
confirmed that both he and sha'lame
would be up for returning Andre ah
someone wants to write another book
Luka wants to write the script Timmy and
I are down as long as they give us each
12 million dollars however not everyone
will be returning if the film gets going
as the first films now Oscar winning
screenwriter James ivory has said he has
no interest in working on a sequel Andre
a seaman on the other hand seems pretty
gung-ho about the whole idea as he's
writing a sequel of his own will the
potential movie take any inspiration
from a seaman's new book or work
Guadagnino do his own thing right now
that remains a mystery do you feel the
need the need for a sequel if not you'd
better get yourself right back into the
danger zone because Pete maverick
Mitchell is soaring back into theaters
next year over 30 years after Top Gun
turns Tom Cruise into a legitimate star
the a-list actor is finally returning
for part two and is not the only
original cast member making a comeback
according to The Wrap Val Kilmer is set
to return as Tom Iceman Kazansky but
don't expect Kafka and maverick to be a
clone of the first film while nobody
knows the plot for sure Variety says
that cruises character will be a flight
instructor and that the movie will quote
explore a world of drone technology
fifth-generation fighters and the end of
the era of dogfighting and to represent
this brand new world miles teller is
playing the son of Mavericks late and
great wingman Nick goose Bradshaw played
in the original by Anthony Edwards
Jennifer Connelly Jon Hamm and Edie
Harris will round out the cast Joseph
Kosinski who previously worked with
cruise on a blip
and broke onto the scene with Tron
Legacy is taking the director's chair
expect top gun maverick to take off on
June 26 2020 widely considers one of
these scariest movies ever made The
Shining certainly seems like a clean-cut
standalone story Jack Torrance dies and
Danny Torrance escapes the Overlook
Hotel what more needs to be said but
there was one person who disagreed with
conventional wisdom and thought the
shining needed a sequel over 35 years
after publishing the original novel
Stephen King returned to the psychic
world of Danny Torrance with dr. sleep
published in 2013 the plot follows a
middle-aged Danny as he overcomes
alcoholism and uses his shining
abilities to help hospice patients find
peace but things get a little bit
complicated after he befriends a young
girl with incredible powers as she's
being hunted by a cult that wants to
feed off her psychic energy following
the success of it Warner Brothers is
adapting dr. sleep for the big screen
and there are some impressive stars
joining the cast Ewan McGregor will play
the older Danny Torrance and Rebecca
Ferguson of Mission Impossible rogue
nation is co-starring as the villain
known as Rose the Hat while Westworld
vet Jean McLaren on is on board to play
her lover and lieutenant Crowe daddy
newcomer Kylie Coran will play Abra
stone the girl with a psychic gift and
we're also going to see the return of
some classic shining characters Alex s O
of starry eyes will play Danny's mother
Wendy Torrance and Carl Lumley will play
the telepathic dick hallorann I think a
lot of things happen right here this
particular down over the years so how
exactly will dr. sleep connect to the
Stanley Kubrick original while speaking
with Bloody Disgusting director Mike
Flanagan said that while this movie
isn't The Shining this sequel will
indeed acknowledge the 1980 horror
classic dr. sleep will be released
November 8 2019 ready for some totally
bodacious news bill S Preston and
Theodore Logan re teaming for another
time ey me Adventure villain Ted faced
the music takes place nearly 30 years
after the duo's bogus journey it finds
the two excellent rock stars
in a serious midlife crisis after a
visitor from the future shows up with a
dire warning Bill and Ted must travel
through time and write a musical
masterpiece that will save all of
space-time along the way the duo will be
joined by their daughters played by
Bridget Lundy Paine will play Ted's
daughter Billie and Samara weaving who
plays Bill's daughter Thea rapper Kid
Cudi is also going to show up although
we don't know who he's going to play
while William Sadler is reprising his
role of death Dean Paris oh of Galaxy
Quest Fame will direct while original
screenwriters Chris Matheson and Ed
Solomon will penned the screenplay and
the legendary Steven Soderbergh will
produce even though a whole lot of time
has passed since the last film
screenwriter Edie Solomon told Collider
that part three will maintain the tone
the sweetness the absurdity of the first
two while being something unique prepare
to witness Bill & Ted's bogus and
incredible new adventure on August 21st
2020 in May 2015 the Hollywood Reporter
announced that Sony was set to remake
the craft the black magic cult classic
from 1996 but as it turns out that
initial report wasn't 100% accurate
instead the filmmakers are taking the
Jurassic world approach setting the film
in the same universe but 20 years after
the first film making it something of a
quasi sequel producer Douglas wick told
HitFix there will be callbacks to the
original movies so you will see there is
a connection between what happened in
the days of the craft and how these new
characters come across this magic many
years later lead geniac of honey moon
who also co-wrote the original draft of
the screenplay will direct as four
actresses
we don't know yet who's joining the high
school coven but Robin Tunney has
expressed interest in returning for part
two here's hoping the rest of the
original cast will bring back some of
the old magic by showing up in
supporting roles
the trippy Jim Henson fantasy labyrinth
is beloved by a seriously diehard cult
following and David Bowie's performances
jerath the Goblin King has gone down in
Hollywood legends so making a sequel to
Henson's final film is bound to be a
pretty intimidating task but fidei
Alvarez is up to the challenge
luckily since Alvar
is best known for directing don't
breathe and the 2013 Evil Dead remake
you should have no problem recreating
the eerie atmosphere of the original at
the moment there aren't any plot details
other than the film will be a direct
continuation of the first movie many
years later
according to Alvarez but rest assured
labyrinth fans there won't be another
actor filling in for Bowie it's
impossible for anyone to replace Ziggy
Stardust after all
so jerath the Goblin King will simply
not appear in the upcoming sequel ensure
the idea of someone tampering with such
a beloved movie is kind of frightening
but Alvarez is approaching this film as
a true fan as he explained to Deadline
labyrinth is one of the seminal movies
from my childhood that made me fall in
love with filmmaking at the moment it
certainly looks like we're in good hands
although fans probably shouldn't hold
their breath for the sequels arrival
Henson Company Chairman Brian Henson
told Forbes in 2018 we're still excited
about the idea we are working on
something but nothing that's close
enough to say it's about to be in
pre-production or anything like that
it's found that the new thing check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]